I'm going to take you out into the
streets show you what's really happening
in this city go ahead to the bottom the
Technical High School represents busy
lack of a plan
I was captain in the robotics team you
know a lot of that funding got cut I
ended up running the streets and
selling weed I'm looking at my life now
and it's like and my education would
have been a little bit better I got
pushed a little harder maybe got one
beer now you got his truancy because
they can't get to school you cannot be
thinking about schooling asthma as a way
to make profit people fought really hard
for public education and that's a right
that we have basically just a lot of
people getting left out
they are responsible for some of the
biggest sources of pollution in the city
that we know cause things like asthma
and cancer the communities that are
around here by the refinery and where
the trains go through predominantly
low-income predominately communities of
color why was Sunday had asthma and we
played outside he thought smell strange
smells
he got come in
this is the site of how Philadelphia has
been transformed in places like this
places that have been remade for
business where millions of dollars have
been poured in but you have huge parts
of Philadelphia that have gone
undeveloped and when development does
happen it looks like more like
gentrification is not development for
the long term resident with the
convention coming to town I think
there's this real question where the
Democrats gonna do to fix it for
working-class communities across fill it
off the end across the country